and Laura former campaign chair for
Trump Paul mana for it was back in court
today what happened there yeah well this
has to do with the search and seizure of
items by federal agents at Paul manna
forts properties now mana forts legal
team is attempting to persuade a federal
judge to suppress or limit the evidence
that was taken by FBI agents in the case
against him particularly what was taken
out of a storage locker Manta Ford's
team argues the person who opened up the
locker for FBI agents had no right to do
so Special Counsel Robert Muller's team
maintains that person's name was on the
lease and they had a key matter forts
team argues that Muller search warrant
was too broad on its face violating the
Fourth Amendment's ban on unreasonable
search and seizures mana for facing
charges of money laundering tax fraud
and failure to register as a foreign
agent this request by man affords team
comes just one week after their attempt
to have the whole case dismissed a
request which was denied